the lockdowns were the first 15 minutes
and then everybody started to lose their
minds then they okay everybody we're
going back to normal everybody come back
out come back out they're going to
re-lock down so the hypothesis goes and
this time they're going to be like don't
don't worry just like last time we'll
we'll lift the lockdown soon it's coming
it's coming but people will go 300 times
longer in lockdown I got a little bit of
a different take from that is that the
the willingness to resist and then
they're in inability to enforce it is
the Hope like that's us getting pulling
ourselves out of the tank realizing like
oh you don't have to submit to this yeah
personally I just see things a little
bit differently I don't think they're
going to try to launch another kind of
pandemic from here I think it's going to
be digital I think there's going to be
an attack on our infrastructure it's
going to lead to a lot of chaos and then
they're going to come in and saying hey
it's dangerous to have an open and free
internet we need to take control of it